- Hello!
I'm so excited.
(audience applauding)
Welcome back you two.
You've been here before, remotely.
- Yes, yes, we're happy
to be here in person.
- So last-
And welcome to the rest of you.
Yes.
I love the film so much.
We're gonna get to it
but I have to say the last
time you were here, Jeff,
we were naming my band
and we settled on "Y'all".
Do you approve?
It doesn't matter.
I'm not changing it.
But do you like it?
(Jeff chuckling)
(Kelly chuckling)
- I like it fine.
Your band could be called anything.
They'd be great.
I have an idea.
Hey, you know, I have a little band.
And we made an album last time
that Miley Cyrus and Fiona Apple sang on.
If you would sing on our
next little recording-
- If you would ask me.
- Would you, please?
- Yes.
- [Jeff] I have an idea.
(audience cheering)
- Jeff's out here making moves. I love it.
- [Kelly] No, no, we've
actually done this again
on Hollywood Game Night.
We were both on the same team.
We sang a little together.
- I have an idea for a song.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- "Don't Fence Me In".
- [Kelly] "Don't fence me in".
- Do you know that?
- No.
♪ Give me land, lots of land. ♪
♪ Bah da da za ba da ga ga. ♪
♪ Don't fence me in. ♪
I like that.
- [Kelly] I like this.
I don't like to be
pigeonholed I'm in, yeah.
(DeWanda and Bryce laughs)
- What are y'all there?
- Put a bookmark there.
An inside joke or something?
Y'all laughed at, right?
- [Bryce] Well, I mean,
Jeff Goldblum is a genius,
a bonafide genius.
- He's actually insane on a piano.
- [Bryce] Yeah.
- Like, I didn't know.
And then I was like, what?
Like we were at some game thing
and I was like, I'm sorry, what?
- [Bryce] It's true.
So whenever he says, I have an idea,
something marvelous is gonna follow it.
- Yeah.
- So that's what he said.
He goes, hey, hey, I have an idea.
And we were like... (gasps)
- Tell us.
Also, all I want from today
is for you two to sing.
So I was like, it was really close.
I just got really close.
- [Kelly] It was so close.
Well, we're gonna do it now.
You all heard it?
- Yes.
- See there's no take backs, Jeff.
- [DeWanda] There are witnesses.
- [Kelly] No take backs.
I would love to sing with you.
So wait, I heard that
actually, was it you two?
It was, you play guitar
and y'all kept everybody
entertained, right?
During the shoot?
- There was some, there was
some music (clears throat).
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To be had.
But mostly it was Jeff at
the piano and people kind
of like joining him 'coz
he can play anything
and it was a lot of fun.
A lot of fun.
- [Jeff] I like to play.
He's a musical genius.
There was a whole evening.
A one-man show.
If you give him a guitar-
- [Kelly] I had no idea.
- Oh yeah, he's great.
- I know. I didn't know.
You play like...
- [Bryce] Yes.
- [DeWanda] He sings.
- [DeWanda] Just all kinds-
- And you sing!?
- How did I miss this?
- I don't-
When Kelly Clarkson asks you if you sing,
you better be able to sing.
- [Kelly] I'm just saying!
- And I can't sing.
- [Kelly] I'm just saying.
It could be a trio moment now.
Cause I didn't know.
He could do that too.
- He sings great.
- I'm in.
- [Jeff] And DeWanda sings-
DeWanda's a wonderful singer.
DeWanda sang with us.
- Again. I echo what Chris just said.
When Kelly Clarkson asked-
- [Kelly] Everyone is backing out.
Everyone is like, I'm not
going karaokeing with you.
Just like it's not happening.
- [Chris] I will, I'll karaoke.
- [Kelly] I love karaoke.
It's so- well obviously a
whole show I started with.
But I love it 'cause it's
funny to do like songs
people don't expect.
So I usually rap.
What do you do at karaoke?
- Oh man.
I, you know, it kind of
depends on how much I've been-
What I've been drinking,
and how much I've been drinking, you know?
- Yes, there is a difference
between like beer and alcohol,
like liquor.
- Yeah, I'm Whitney Houston
when I'm really drunk.
- Wow.
- But you know, I'm like
- [Kelly] I think we all are.
Pour Some Sugar on Me
when I'm just buzzed.
- [Kelly] Yes. Okay.
Okay. What's your go-to for karaoke?
- I don't drink.
- I don't drink, well, you
don't have to drink. (coughs)
- That's a good answer.
- Like, I don't drink,
therefore I don't do karaoke.
- Therefore those two can't
exist without the other.
That's amazing.
- Correct. Correct.
The last time I did
karaoke was with Amy Adams
and I retired after that.
Have you ever done karaoke with her?
- No, but I've sung with her in Enchanted.
We sung great together
at home when I sing with her.
- She's serious about karaoke.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Very serious.
- She's got a great voice.
- Yes. So I said there's,
- [Kelly] But that's actually
- I'm not gonna take up
anymore space in the karaoke world.
- [Kelly] So people
aren't supposed to be like
real at karaoke.
- [Chris] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, you're supposed to like be funny.
You're supposed to do some kind
of funny, like if you really are a singer.
- She managed to do all of those things.
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay.
- She's-
- Well go ahead, Amy Adams.
- Yeah.
- Fabulous at everything.
What do y'all do?
Y'all like karaoke?
You, well you do it.
You probably sing everything.
So yeah. Yeah.
DeWanda, what's your go-to?
- See, that's the thing,
Bryce and I are secretly twins.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So I also do not drink,
therefore I do not do karaoke.
- We always learn about new things
like every five minutes or so.
- Every five minutes at least.
- Yeah.
- We've never discussed
this prior to this moment.
- This is news, but not news.
- Yes.
- Okay. So wait, what about
you, Mamoudou, what do you do?
- Twist and shout.
I also don't drink by the way.
Twist and Shout.
- [Kelly] You don't drink either?
- Ah.
Okay. You don't have to drink.
I just, it's an interesting thing.
- Yeah. Just up Twist and Shout
and Sympathy For The Devil
- (Together) Sympathy For The Devil?
♪ Please excuse me while I (mumbles) ♪
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my God, oh my God
(audience cheering)
That was a look at the new film.
It's incredible.
It's in theater starting tomorrow.
So Chris, Bryce, and Jeff
like what brought you back
to do another "Jurassic World"?
- Well, I mean, this is a, this is
this is the finale of the
"Jurassic World" trilogy.
And so we've done three
"Jurassic World" films
but it also uniquely is wrapping
up the "Jurassic Park"
trilogy in the same movie.
So really it's a finale for
both of these trilogies.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so you've had the,
the legacy cast of, of
course, Mr. Jeff Goldblum.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Sam Neil and Laura Dern as you,
as you saw in the video,
BD Wong, all from the
original film coming back in
and it's really just this
extraordinary finale.
And so it's, this is our, our
last this is like, you know
kind of the Swan song as the
as these characters and
really the grand finale
like you would expect to
see maybe at a, you know
a firework show or something.
It just like it.
The minute they, the
minute the movie starts
it just explodes for two
straight hours as you saw it.
- [Kelly] It does. It's
so like intense, yeah.
But what, what brought you back?
- I mean, all of the things
that Chris was saying
it's pretty crazy to actually be a part
of the Jurassic franchise at all.
- [Kelly] It's like the best.
- [Bryce] It's insane.
I was, I was 12 years old when
the original "Jurassic Park"
came out in 1993.
Chris was 13 years old.
We both saw it opening
weekend and it totally
changed my life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Because it made me feel like, oh my gosh
there's something possible at the movies
that is impossible everywhere else.
- Yeah.
- [Bryce] And so to get
to be a part of this,
of this franchise and then now,
with the legacy cast
coming back and wrapping
up, like Chris said, you know
both of those stories that,
you know, one of them
got started 30 years ago.
I mean, it is a huge honor.
- [Kelly] It was so clever too.
How it all, how everybody
ran into each other,
how everybody was, it wasn't like forced.
I was like, how are they gonna play this?
I was like, it was interesting.
What brought you back, down there?
(Kelly chuckles)
- Well, I wouldn't have missed it
for the world to be with Sam
and Laura again, you know?
(audience applauding)
Thank God.
They changed my life.
I'd be a different person
if I'd never met them.
They're great artists and great people.
And then Colin Trevorrow,
who wrote along with Emily Carmichael,
devised this very good way
to bring us all together.
I'd been a fan of hers.
I'd been a fan of his.
Campbell Scott is in it.
Dichen Lachman. Omar Sy is back.
And it's just a great cast.
And Steven Spielberg is
still the godfather, you know
watching over the whole thing
from the start to the
finish, and over the decades
I'd seen people come up
to me and you know, go,
oh my kids have seen it a hundred times,
it's meant so much to us.
I just love everything about it.
- Yeah. I agree. I agree.
(audience applauding)
It's a family favorite,
like, and it's generational.
That's what's so cool about it.
So y'all are new.
And I was gonna say, DeWanda,
I love your character.
I was like, oh, she gon' be badass.
(DeWanda laughs)
I was like very excited about it.
Did you love like becoming a part of this?
- Yeah. It's a, to your point.
I mean, it's the greatest
franchise of all time.
And I just feel really
fortunate that I was like
back in this beyond epic way, you know
bringing back the legacy characters.
I just, I feel very, very grateful. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah. And Mamoudou,
like this is your first
time doing this too.
So like, what was it
like to be a part of it?
- It was nuts.
- [Kelly] Is it kind of intimidating?
'coz you're walking on
set and you're like, okay.
- Yeah. My first day on
set was with Laura and Sam
and you know I grew up with them watching.
This was the first like big blockbuster
movie I ever saw as a kid.
So to see them and I admired
them as actors forever
as a kid and as an adult to see them
as those characters and work opposite them
I constantly found myself
just like, wait, am I
am I really here?
Is this a real thing?
But they really made
it just so comfortable
and a really pleasant
experience, as did these guys.
- [Kelly] Oh that's awesome.